water you might not see it but this is
probably the strangest thing in the
universe here's why all of the water on
Earth is alien they might be a familiar
part of our world but our oceans formed
hundreds of millions of years after our
planet took shape the water arrived on
asteroids and comets from space water
doesn't follow the normal rules of
chemistry for a start it shouldn't
really be a liquid on our planet and
unlike any other chemical when water
freezes it expands and so ice floats on
water water molecules can flow upwards
against the force of gravity that's how
oxygen and nutrients reach the edges of
your brain so pour yourself a glass of
water now and take a good look at this
colorless featureless and tasteless
material it breaks so many rules of
chemistry that scientists struggle to
understand it but without its Rebel
Behavior none of us nor our world will
exist